we know that this is a very numerate
prime minister he worked in hedge funds
and in the city before he went into
politics he's a dab hand making a
spreadsheet and he really prizes
numeracy and mathematical ability and
and the thrust of this speech was to try
and Cascade that if you like to the
whole of the country he talked about
maths being taught until between 16 and
18 so beyond GCC he said that didn't
necessarily mean kids needed to study
a-level maths but could they find a way
of making sure just with literacy that
numeracy became really core to learning
and he talked about a review in which
they're going to look how to do that he
talked about building more maths hubs
and he talked about more qualifications
for Primary School teachers when it came
to maths but look the big elephant in
the room there Ian when he talked about
this ambition for maths is the reality
of kids in state schools across the UK
he said it himself that in England and
Wales only a third of children a third
of children sorry fail maths gcscs and
we know that in state schools uh in
England and Wales nearly half of maths
teachers are non-specialized in maths
which really goes back to the basics of
education and not about whether this is
a cultural issue which is what the Prime
Minister talked about about us being an
anti-maths mindset in this country but
rather was it a provision issue and he
acknowledged that the government needed
to do more and and make this a more
integrated policy but I think the sort
of ambition was there I think it's where
the rubber meets the road in terms of
the reality of what state school kids in
places like this in Islington in North
London are experience in the classrooms
and Beth obviously the PM's grappling
with some very uh heavy public sector
strikes particularly in the NHS has he
had anything to say on that this morning
well exactly and that was another area
of questions there's already been uh six
teachers strikes uh this year a couple
more planned and as you said uh the
Royal College of nurses say that their
members have not accepted the
government's payoff and now there is the
prospects of t uh nurses strikes running
uh into Christmas the Prime Minister
obviously asked about that he says he's
disappointed
um that uh public sector workers haven't
accepted the deals but hopes to find a
way through but I'm afraid in for now no
more detail